Hello, everybody. Welcome to another holistic health hour Q&A. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters.
Remember everybody to go to holisticcaleshour.com. You can see past episodes. It's also well indexed
so you can find different topics that you might be trying to search for.
Also a reminder to go to CuttersClinic.com. That's our main website.
And you'll see well over a thousand blog posts on different topics that you might have some curiosity as well.
From the holistichealthhour.com you can ask questions. You can also ask questions on this live chat.
As soon as I connect with chat, we're like right now. So you can feel free to chat in questions as well.
But on the holistichealthhour.com is a box where you could add questions. And that's where I'm going to be taking today's questions from to begin with.
So here's first one. What are your thoughts on cortical steroids like flow days, nasal sprays, or allergies or steroid inhalers for asthma management?
Well, again, I'm one of those functional doctors who believe that sometimes the use of medication is wise.
So I don't think that it's healthy to take a dogmatic position against those things like all because they're medication. I never want to use them.
But I also think it's foolish to take a dogmatic position that oh my doctor told me to take this or this seems to work for me.
So I'm just going to keep taking it blindly without doing some research. So I think you have to have a balanced approach.
I think there's oftentimes a need for using cortical steroids. Oftentimes indeed for using asthma medication on a daily basis.
A lot of times you need to be taking medication on a daily basis. But if you're not asking deeper questions like why do I have asthma?
And I need to get to the bottom of this. Then I think you're that's that's not wise at all.
So I think we need to dig to find the causes of our disorders instead of thinking that we are the victim of some named disease.
Oh I am asthma. My mom had asthma. My sister has asthma. It runs into family. Oh does it.
Or if you all have a sensitivity because of a familial trait that you all lived in a multi house or that you all ate the same foods or what is it?
You got to dig to the bottom of this. So finding out in case of asthma is very often healing the gut and healing food sensitivities.
That is a key component of actually getting a person off of the long term puzzle medication.
Question from the chat. You can chat in your questions. How do you handle the vertigo from with the rolls naturally?
So vertigo is an issue with your temporal nerve or your cerebellum that is back part of the brain back here.
Temporal nerve is in your ear here in your deep part of the temporal lobe of the brain or it's part of the vestibular system.
So there's multiple different causes for vertigo.
Vertigo from with the rolls. Now quite honestly I have never dealt with vertigo from with the rolls. So if you had to find out going to.
If you are going to really dig to the bottom of that help with that going to somebody who does functional neurology.
So there's a whole class of care that people that are what are called functional neurologists, not a regular medical neurologist.
So functional neurologist is looking for causes different neurological disorders. There's different tests that can be done through in a good functional neurology clinic to get to root cause of different types.
So vertigo and then different specific exercises to that can help a person with that whatever type of vertigo that is.
So that's the way I would approach that. If he has it to the sale just take this supplement or it's just not that easy.
You have to decrease the inflammation of the brain is really what the thing is, but and you've got to find out where that inflammation is.
So going to somebody who's would be listed as a functional neurologist specifically somebody who's gone through Karek that's C-A-R-R-I-C-K education.
I've done a lot of that, but we don't see people in the office anymore. It'll practice functional neurology and the office anymore.
This is really an office exam that needs to be done a functional neurological exam.
And so Karek functional neurologist is what you want to look up.
I apologize I can't give you a quick answer for that cause it's not a quick answer.
Any time when you have when you're dealing with inflammation that is neurological inflammation from what a semi quick answer, decreasing inflammation is the key.
So with any even a person is going to a functional neurologist and they do its specific neurological exercises to help with that function of that nerve using anti-inflammatories.
Which are fitted to the bioflavidoid category. Those are things like tuberic, EG-C-G-Resvera-Tral, Boswellia, Chorsatin, Rosemary.
I mean there's a lot of nutrients that fitted that flavidoid category that have been shown time and time again in different studies to decrease inflammation of the brain.
Really that's really the only thing that really decreases inflammation in the brain.
I would, you know, lease from a functional metabolic standpoint. I would consider those types of things.
But getting a good functional neurological examination like we have a word.
Next question. What are your thoughts on electrolyte drinks specifically?
Is that okay to use or should I avoid it? The ingredients are sparkly, water, salt, citric acid, magnesium, malate, potassium chloride, natural flavor, and stevia.
So electrolyte drinks. So what are our electrolytes? So electrolytes are minerals that your body needs.
Why does our body need more minerals? Well, when you sweat out minerals, if you're doing like sauna therapy on a daily basis, you could be sweating out and losing a lot of minerals.
If you're outside working in the summer heat, definitely supplementing with minerals slash electrolytes would be a very wise thing. If you're an athlete and you're working out heavily, you're sweating out a lot of your minerals.
So there's nothing wrong with taking electrolyte drinks. It could be a very wise thing to take if you're fitted in those kind of categories.
If you're not outside, you're not sweating out those things and you measured these things in a blood test, which anybody who does a CBC and a complete metabolic panel, they're going to measure their sodium, their chloride, their potassium, and their calcium levels in their blood.
Now, normally, those are all those electrolytes are also function as buffering components of the blood. So if your blood is off those, then your electrolytes are way out of balance.
So from a functional standpoint, you have to use wisdom because they won't be out of balance on a blood test until you've done a lot of insult.
So just from going out sweating, really hard, maybe several days in a row, typically your blood values are going to still be within normal range.
But if you're dehydrated, you're not getting in your minerals through your food somehow, maybe you have some gut issues, so you're not absorbing minerals real well.
Maybe your diet is poor and you're then out sweating and losing minerals, you can show differences in blood tests quite quickly.
However, your body is constantly trying to buffer the blood in order to keep a pH of 7.3, 4, 3, 5, or whatever it has to be, and it is using minerals from other parts of your body, pull it into the blood.
So taking electrolyte, using electrolyte drinks, taking minerals, taking a good mineral supplement is a wise thing to do most.
Most electrolyte drinks have a decent quality mineral. I do have a video, I think it's on our blog site, a video on a blog on good minerals versus bad minerals.
That's very important to look at, so I would suggest you go to Cutters Clinic and search that out, I don't know what the title of the article is, on the head.
But there's supplements out there that really utilize really pretty minerals, and you'll see in that article that I'm very much against the liquid ionic minerals that are kind of a hot topic in the nutritional space right now.
I think those are really very poor quality minerals, that's not how we're supposed to get our minerals. The ingredients that you listed off in this, the salt is just sodium chloride.
That is replacing the sodium in the chloride in your gut, in your bloodstream, in your body, citric acid is just a carrier and something to help with the taste.
Magnesium valet is a good source of magnesium. Potassium chloride is a decent source of potassium, so I don't have any problem with the ingredients in this.
But there are some minerals out there that use calcium carbonate, really, that's just limestone, that's like eating dirt, that's just really poor quality, potassium carbonate, really poor quality magnesium carbonates, just really, it's like eating dirt.
And it's not how we're supposed to get our minerals, but it's super cheap, so a lot of companies don't care about if it's good quality or not, they're just trying to sell supplements.
Those are typically supplements that you're going to buy in Wal-Mart or Charger or something like that, so you want to stay away from that kind of stuff and use a good quality nutritional supplements.
Taking bad quality minerals, not only is it good for you, but it can be harmful for you because it can take up an absorption site that if you're getting good minerals from your diet, then you don't absorb good those good minerals.
So it can be do you more harm than good, even besides the fact that it can damage, can cause other damage.
Okay, next question, what do you think is the best type of testing to have done in order to help to determine what diet will likely work for a person?
Well, this is kind of a loaded question.
When we see a person that has a diagnosis of cancer, we do testing our cheek swab testing to find out what we think is feeding the cancer and then take off, take those things out of a person's diet.
So cancer can be fed through different fuel sources, can be fed through different metabolic processes, and you have to often change the diet because it can bite a fuel source.
I don't know if this person is asking about cancer or not.
So, so let's shift a little bit. So if I don't have cancer, what kind of diet should I be doing? Should I be doing a cardamom or diet? Should I be doing a keto diet? Should I be doing?
There's tons of different bad diets out there.
What's a good one to be on?
Well, what's a good one to be on is one that is right for your body. How do I know what's right for my body?
Well, to test your gut and see what you are not reacting to.
So if a person has health issues, you want to at least be one of the initial components of an evaluation is to look at a person's gut because you want just what you eat, you are what you absorb, you are what you retain, you are what you don't detoxify.
And we are exposed to so many things that damage our gut, and once our gut is damaged, then we can develop antibodies to foods that are actually good, that are healthy foods.
But we if we have antibodies to that healthy food, every time we eat that healthy food, we're causing more inflammation and more damage to our gut.
So how do I know that without testing for it? So running some labs is really the way to go when you're looking at what is the best diet for me.
Okay, here's an example.
Well, I'm going to go on a carnivore diet because I heard about this person who had an auto-view disease and they went on a carnivore diet, they basically really called everything down and quote unquote cured their problem.
Well, the truth is that can be bad for some people. If you ran an antibody tested, you have antibodies to meats, and you're eating meat that you have antibodies to, you're not going to call them things down and it's not going to work for you.
That person that it worked for, obviously didn't have antibodies to meat. Maybe an antibody still whole bunch of things but not meat.
At least the meat he was choosing, he or she was choosing to eat, and they ate those meats and then they weren't eating the things that they had antibodies against.
And that called the inflammation down and they were able to do other things to heal their gut so that those antibodies to those other foods may be slowly dissipated,
and the antibodies to foods for the most part will dissipate over time, and they were able to go on a back to a fairly normal diet and their problem was helped very much.
So the way you find out what diet is best for you is to run some tests. So there's different lab tests that you can run.
I would start with like Syrex Array 2 to see the level of damage of the gut wall first, and if that exists, depending on the person's symptoms, I would make clinical decisions from that.
So how I make clinical decisions is for to discuss with the person, get a fairly good health history, know what's going on, know what are some goals are where we want to move from there.
That's what we call case review. So if you want to do a case review with me over the phone, you can do so you can find out information you can schedule it yourself on cuttersclinic.com.
So that's what I thought about that. You want to test as many things as you can when you're trying to make clinical decisions.
You want to try to base it as much on objective findings as you possibly can.
Next question. I had an Array 2 test. Oh, where we are. I had a Syrex Array 2 test come back normal. I'm still waiting for Array 10 test to come back.
Array 5 test showed positive thyroid peroxidase antibodies. I already know I have Lyme and cool infections. What suggestions do you have? What next steps to take?
Well, I would so if you okay, so if Array 2 came back normal, that means you don't have enough damage to your gut to show positive.
That's what the Array 2 Syrex Array 2 tests for leaky gut in layman's terms.
So permeability issues with the gut. If that came back normal, that's a really good thing.
It doesn't mean that you still can't have food antibodies. So Array 10 is going to test for that. If that all comes back normal, then that's a very good thing.
Then what came back abnormal with this person in Array 5, which is self a test for self antibodies, this person showed high thyroid peroxidase antibodies.
What does that mean? Well, you have to look whether that person has either Hashimoto's, most likely, or has hyperthyroidism.
And that would be based upon their thyroid levels. If their T3 was really high, then that person has hyperthyroidism. And then we have to deal with that.
That means they have antibodies against the thyroid. So they know that they have an autoimmune thyroid.
So when a person has self antibodies to whatever, then they have to be aware, now that they know that they have an autoimmune condition, they have to be aware of everything else they do.
Because anything that's going to stimulate in immune response is going to make that autoimmune condition worse.
So most likely this person has Hashimoto's, I don't know what their levels of their thyroid is, but that would be most common.
And so the next steps are to wait till they get Array 10 tests back to know what foods they can or cannot eat.
If Array 10 test is all negative, then are there any food restrictions with an autoimmune thyroid?
Well, there are, regardless of whether they have antibodies to gluten, this person cannot eat gluten.
So there's a side note, if you have any thyroid issues, whether it be primary hypothyroidism, whether you have hyperthyroid, or whether you have Hashimoto's, or an autoimmune thyroid, you cannot be eating gluten.
Why? Because gliaticism molecular mimic to the thyroid.
So the presence of gliatic in that person's diet, anti-thyroid, and gliatic, whether they have antibodies or not to gluten, will cause a reaction to the thyroid and will make the thyroid worse.
So you can't eat gluten. So even if you don't have antibodies to gluten, even if Array 10 comes back all normal, you can't eat gluten.
If Array 10 comes back all normal, can they eat all the other foods that are on there? Yeah, they typically don't have problems eating any of those other foods on there.
So, but they have to be aware of other things that could stimulate their immune system.
So they're taking it because they have live and co-infections, and some practitioner has them on a vitamin C therapy, or a cat's claw, common supplement with live, or a condition or a strangleist or something like that.
Those are all no notes because those are all immune stimulants.
And if you have antibodies to self tissue, you can't be taking those immune stimulants on a regular basis.
Yeah, if you feel like you're coming down with a cold or something like that to take them short term, that's acceptable.
But if you're going to take a long term, all you're doing is stimulating your immune response, and you will kill that what you have antibodies against first.
That's the rule of your immune system.
So if you have self antibodies, and you're going to stimulate the immune response, gets what you're going to start killing.
You're going to kill that what you have antibodies against first in this case, thyroid gland.
So I have a whole bunch more information on that on our chronic disease and autoimmune course.
If you're interested, if you know that you already have an autoimmune disease, definitely that $50 is worth spending to take that course because I got tons of tons of information on that.
Question from the chat, is there a detox supplement or regimen that is not hard on the kidneys?
I heard what does it want to overload the kidneys?
Well, I would agree, and the other thing that I would be careful with with a detox supplement is making sure you're some all the phases of detox.
In school, you learn that there's really two, probably years ago, you went to school, and now three phases of detox in the liver.
There's phase one, phase two in the liver, then phase three would be getting the detox metabolites into the bile in order for it to carry into the gallbladder and into the small attestin.
I call that part phase four, and then carried through the intestinal tract, I call that phase five, so they don't reabsorb it.
So by needed in the gut would be in phase five, and then phase six is getting it deposited into the toilet.
So when you're talking about a detox supplement, usually a detox supplement or a detox protocol is something that's going to either key light things out of the teeth.
Things out of the tissues key later, or a detox supplement or detox protocol is supporting phase one and phase two in the liver.
Now, I'd be okay, taking supporting phase one and phase two in the liver, but still you want to make sure your phase six, making sure you have regular bowel movements, your phase five, making sure that you're not reabsorb it.
Testine still transits time is fast enough that you're not just reabsorbing things in the larger testin that your liver works so hard to jump into the bile to dump into the small attestin.
Now you're reabsorb it into the large attestin. That's not a good thing. That's phase five, making sure that your gallbladder is healthy enough to store and dump that bile into the small attestin.
It's not a sluggish gallbladder, stones in there that you need to deal with.
And before I would make sure on those three, this is before I would start supporting liver, or at least concurrently whilst supporting liver detoxification in pathways.
And so certainly you don't want to be used to key later pulling stuff out of the tissue before you've supported all those other pathways. That's what I call phase zero.
So I don't think anybody has any business, you know, pulling stuff out of the tissue until they made sure all those other pathways are nice and clear.
That's what I call the seven phases of detox. You can download.
You can watch the videos on our blog post. I go into detail. I actually have a whole course on the seven phases of detox in the book on it, but you can get the just of what I said on our blog post.
If you look up seven phases of detox, I can create some videos on it too.
When I did p3dish mold testing in my bathroom, one thing it showed was high candida.
A husband and I don't have any symptoms of this.
Should we test or treat ourselves for candida?
So this person is talking about using a company called Immutal Linux lab, where you put these little petri dishes in different parts of your house, testing for do I have mold growing in my house that I need to deal with.
It's a good thing for everybody to do, you know, these ones in their home.
Because you could have hidden mold behind the wall and you can't see it, you know, you can't smell it.
And you could be exposed to mycotoxins because of those things.
Now, if you do have that, you should remediate that area. So you should clean that area with recommendations that this company may give you.
You should be searching for different ways to decrease that candida in this case, whatever mold is present.
Should you treat your body for candida if you had candida exposure? No, I wouldn't say so.
If I had no symptoms of candida and, you know, never did, should I treat my body for candida?
I would say no, I would not. Just because you're exposed to something doesn't mean that it is a problem.
And mycotoxin test, mycotox test is not going to test for candida because candida is a living organism.
But it's a yeast that's not so a mycotoxin is a toxin that different molds give off.
It's not the mold itself. So mycotox test is not testing for living organisms in my body, living molds in my body, living yeast in my body.
Mycotox test is tested for the toxins that those living things can give off that you then can breathe in.
So in this case, no, I would treat for that unless you had symptoms.
There's different tests that you could do to see if you have candida, but I wouldn't even spend anybody on those labs if I didn't have the symptoms.
Next question. Hi, Dr. counters. Any advice for sudden itchy skin rashes appearing on a couple of different parts of the body?
Looking something like possible psoriasis on one part, it's still there after three months, turning more red and now covering a larger area.
One natural suggestion was aloe vera. Thanks for your input.
Yeah, well, you do want to try to figure out what the cause of this is because you have different causes for different rashes.
If it is psoriasis, then that ties to autoimmune issues if it's more of a simple contact dermatitis, which can last for a long period of time at different times, especially when you haven't figured out.
The thing that you're reacting to that is that you've come in contact with.
So if you're always, whenever you have rashes, you want to try to get a diagnosis. There's different virus and different fungi, different bacteria that can cause rashes, especially in childhood rashes, very common.
You could go on Google and search for pictures of that different rash. If it looks like a psoriasis, it's not always definitive and you can't always figure that out.
Definitely with any rashes, you want to consider different contact issues.
Meaning do I have this rash because of my laundry detergent? Do I have this rash because of something you're exposing yourself to.
A cream that you're putting on a lotion, a sunscreen block, something like that.
But honestly, those are the most common causes of issues like that.
Toxic exposure, not just topically, can cause rashes.
Remember, your skin is an organ of detoxification. So many times you'll break out of the rash because you're exposed to something you're breathing in.
So I've had patients that bought a new piece of furniture.
And what, what would that be? New piece of furniture. Well, almost all furniture by law is made with fabric that's heavily sprayed with chemical flavor retardants, fire retardants.
Fire retardant chemicals, you could be highly sensitive to.
And one doctor is just years ago, called me his, I don't remember the total stories, 12-year-old son's.
Frankie, I remember the symptom pattern that was going on with 12-year-old son.
The distance testing on him came up fire retardant. I said, I don't know, it's coming up fire retardant. Maybe this is totally wrong.
But that's what's coming up in the doctor said, oh my gosh, we bought a brand new couch three months ago and he's been sleeping on that couch.
All they did is change where he was sleeping. It is a symptoms one way. So, yes, exposure to chemicals is a huge thing.
So look at, you know, you're going to put on your shirt lock homes hat a little bit and start digging into where have I exposed to different chemicals?
Is it in the yard? Is it people sprayed stuff? Is it things I breed it in? Is it things I've eaten?
There's just food sensitivities can cause that. It just goes on and on and on.
So short of doing, you know, some more extensive functional medicine tests.
That's the thing I would start with. If I was going to, we've done all that, we can't figure it out.
But what would I do next? I would look at got issues. I would start with Syrix array two and see if I have got permeability issues because that's very kind of a skin for ashes.
Okay, time for a couple more questions here.
Okay, here's what the came in should I take a binder on an empty stomach. So a binder. So a binder is something.
That before I was talking about the seven phases of detoxification phase five in my book is grabbing onto stuff in the gut.
So it stays in the gut. Well, eventually it's causing the toilet, but stays in the gut and not reabsorbed.
So you don't want to be a reabsorbed toxic. You want to reabsorb water in the last part of the larger test.
You want to be absorbing, reabsorbing hormones, estrogens or commonly reabsorbed by females in the last part of the larger test.
The toxins that your liver were so hard to get rid of and dump into the small intestine can be reabsorbed.
If you're a test, especially if you're a test of transit time is slow and or you have a test of permeability issues, maybe you have leaky gut.
So using a binder is, you know, different pelvic acids, humic acid, different clays, different.
There's a lot of different binders on the market that are really good that just grab onto things in the gut.
And binders typically will stay in the gut and hold things in the gut so it can be deposited into the toilet.
Should you take those on an empty stomach? Generally, yes.
Why? Why can't I just take them with that food? Because they can bind minerals too.
So if you're getting your minerals through your food, they can be bound by those binders. We don't want to do that.
So typically you take them about 30 to 60 minutes away from food. That's typically how you take binders.
Question from the chat. Can a zeolite product be helpful for someone fighting cancer? Sure. So zeolite is not a cancer killer.
No, but zeolite, it functions actually as a binder and as a key later because you do absorb zeolite.
So it does function as a key later too. So key lady X and 7 phase of detox is phase zero.
So again, you have to make sure you're supporting all those other phases before you start taking zeolite or EDTA or DMSA, which is those are more heavy key laders.
So, but yes, key lady toxins out of your body can be very beneficial. So if you're having supporting the liver and making sure you're ever in a bowel movement,
you're doing coffee and some things like that, supporting bio flow, supporting your gobladder, using hot packs over your liver, using key laders by all means can be extremely helpful with anybody with any health condition.
Is it going to be a cancer killer to kill cancer cells? In my opinion, no, not at all. But you're not just trying to kill cancer cells.
You're trying to take burdens off your body so your immune system can kill cancer cells. So all those things, you don't just treat the cancer.
You treat the person, which maybe has cancer because of toxins, which is the number one cause of cancer.
So remember cancer is anything caused by anything that gets inside the cell and damages the DNA replication, when it goes into rapid replication, that is by definition what cancer is.
That's an outside cell. It's your own cell that is in rapid replication, is replicating damage DNA that are replicating damage DNA.
And you've got this rapid replication of cells that you get this growing mass that's continuing to replicate.
And most commonly, you can have a myotoxin cause, but most commonly, it's a toxic cause.
So something gets inside that cell and cause that replication to take place.
So detoxification has got to be a part of that person's healing for sure.
So using the zeolite can be a good way to help with that.
Do you think everyone needs to be taking fish oils?
No, I don't. I don't think everybody needs to be taking fish oils quite honestly. I don't take fish oils.
I don't think everybody needs to be taking tons and tons of supplements, period, because I think supplements are supposed to supplement your diet.
Yeah, but I mean, their diets are so poor. Our soil is so depleted and we're deficient in minerals and nutrients.
Yeah, that's why you do take supplements. That's why you try to eat better. That's why you try to grow your food. That's why you try to do those things. And yes, you do take supplements.
Does everybody need to be on fish oils? No, I don't think so. But fish oils are so good. Look at all these articles that show how beneficial fish oils are and stuff.
But if you feel led that you need to be personally taking fish oils and by all means do it, I try not to put people on supplement overload where they just burn out.
They can't take anything anymore because they're just fried.
So fish oils is not one of the things that I readily recommend. I think you should be getting your fats through your foods.
So now if you are on a vegetarian diet, yeah, you probably need to be adding oils and fats to your diet.
But even vegetarians are smart enough, usually well-trained enough to be cooking in good oils and things so they're getting oils in their diet.
I just don't think what God created is that he put cold water fish initially put us in a garden in the middle of a desert.
So people live in deserts, people live in there's people groups that live off of fish oils that eat just fat from cold water fish and they survive it.
They don't seem to get any vegetables. There's people groups that have never seen a fish cold water fish are fish well in their life and they seem to flourish.
So it depends on your body type. It depends on your needs. There's genetic factors that feed into this as well.
That's when we look at people's genetics. Sometimes people do need more oils and illiterate diet.
But I don't want to say that everybody needs to be taking 100 different supplements. I don't think people in general need to do that.
I think there's people that are well-benefit from taking fish oils. I don't think there's a whole lot of supplements that quote-unquote everybody needs to be taking.
So I think supplements should be used to supplement the person's diet. I think there's different times in one's life that you need more minerals like we discussed earlier in today's call.
But there's different times in your life. You may need more oils. There's different times in your life. You need more immune support. There's different times in your life. You need less of all those things.
So I think you need to balance that out. Hey, I have an appointment to go to today. So we're going to call that our time.
Remember to go to ConnorsConnect.com if you didn't get your questions answered. And you probably find a blog post about it in some videos that I've already created.
Look at our courses. Highly recommend the auto-acronic disease and auto-immune course. Anybody that's got any type of challenges, health-wise.
And you can schedule a case review with me anytime you can schedule right off our website. If you want to call our clinic, you can do that as well.
And I forgot to mention today's call for today only using the code HHH5. That's holistic. Help our HHH5. You get 5% off of all supplements in our store today only.
Tell them in the night. I forgot to mention that earlier. So go to our store, use code HHH5. And you can get 5% off all of our supplements.
But it's only for today only. All right. Well, thanks so much. God bless all of you. And we'll see you next week. Bye.